so what is going on let's find out from
the former Chief of the general staff
and that's Lord hello my Lord thanks
this morning joining us it's always
great to see what on Earth is going on
what's your interpretation well it's a
very interesting move that Putin has put
garasimov in charge now grazimov is the
chief of the general staff so he is the
number one soldier in Russia and I think
you can probably interpret this as being
something of a sign of desperation
surakovan who was put in place in
October had a fearsome reputation as
being the person that reduced a leper
and Syria to nothing so it was really
felt that he was the really hard man
that could make a difference well he
clearly hasn't been able to make a
difference the other problem is you've
got quite retention between mercenary
groups and the proper Russian armed
forces the Wagner group has been trying
to take backward for some time terribly
Keen to achieve a success and to say to
Putin or we can do it even if your army
can't do it but actually they're
struggling and they haven't done it very
well so this attack on solidar which is
a way of trying to get to bakrid is
another throw of the dice but it's
really interesting that putting nine
some desperation has put gerasimov in
overall charge what's happening in
solidar
well it would appear that um pretty
World War One tactics are being employed
um a large number of what do you mean by
that a large number of Russian soldiers
probably many of those recently
conscripted in the Army therefore pretty
poorly trained have been thrown forward
in sort of human wave type attacks and
satellite imagery shows a vast number of
dead bodies in the area where there's
fighting going on the Wagner group tried
to claim a couple of days ago that
they'd taken solidar both the Russian
and the Ukrainian Ministry of Defense
said well actually we're not quite so
sure about it so this actually
underlines the tensions between the
commanders of the Wagner group that
individual is trying very hard to get um
a high profile with Putin himself and
the tensions and the leadership of the
Russian army hence Putin has put
grazimov in overall charge it's a bit of
a last throw of the dice it's a little
bit like General Patrick Sanders our
chief the general staff suddenly being
sent from London to wherever we've got a
campaign going on because the
government's getting desperate so it's
it's very interesting to watch this
development what do we know about the
Wagner group
well we know it's a mercenary group
that's been in existence for quite a
number of years it's been a kind of
proxy for Russian foreign policy and
Russian military around the world
um pretty active in sub-Saharan Africa
for example
um it's a pretty nasty organization uh
it's it's led by someone with a very
very murky background who is I'm sure
you've shown the pictures in the past of
him going around prisons
um
promising
um Freedom if you come and fight to
convicts so it's populated with a lot of
pretty nasty people who've got not much
to lose in life I mean if you've been
sentenced for some foul crime and you're
in jail for probably the rest of the
rest of your life the opportunity to at
least try and save a bit of your life by
going to fight is quite a high
motivation so it's it's frankly it's a
sort of typically Russian move you'd
never see it happening in the west and
it's pretty disgraceful actually
suggestions that they may be responsible
for The Disappearance of um two men to
British men Christopher Parry 28 Andrew
Bagshaw who is 48 and suggestions that a
body has been found
well I I mean I can't comment on on that
detail I think
as far as those two are concerned one
has to say well top marks for them for
wanting to have the human motivation to
go and help but of course I think
anybody thinking of doing that must
realize that the risks are pretty high
so if you are motivated
um and I would advise people not to go
and become mercenaries but people want
to go out to that part of the world as
Aid workers to try and help well the
motivation is admirable but they've got
to make sure that their Jolly carefully
look after themselves and that they
don't put themselves in undue in undue
danger there's always some danger but
they should be really quite careful of
measuring the risks to their own
personal safety talk to me about
Challenger tanks we're suggesting that
uh 12 will go that's what Ben Wallace is
suggesting is that enough
well I don't think so
um I mean I I wrote a piece in one of
the newspapers yesterday saying that um
the principle of sending some is Right
12 sounds pretty tokenistic to me given
that we're only planning in this country
to upgrade to Challenger 3 status
136 of our tanks and we have many more
than that it would seem that 12 is too
tokenistic and I would suggest sitting
25 or 30 or even as many as 50. that
would make a real difference How would
how does it make a difference on the
battlefield
well where we are in the campaign is
we're probably going to see the Russians
Mount some other form of offensive
um late winter early spring
the ukrainians Now supported even
increasingly by the west and
particularly if we decide to give them
tanks and infantry fighting Vehicles
should then be strong enough to mount a
significant counter-offensive and if
they can do that well there is a chance
that they could
strike decisive blows on the Russians
perhaps even to break the morale of the
Russian soldiers
and of course what's so important about
that is that I can't see most people
can't see a negotiated settlement at
this war the opening positions are just
irreconcilable so if there's going to be
a conclusion to this war in 2023 it's
going to have to come on the battlefield
so the point really is that the West
America France Britain Germany really
needs to get stuck in and behind and
provide offensive capability to the
ukrainians so that they can mount an
effective counter-offensive break the
will of the Russian army and actually
win this war that's what it's about now
we don't want to be here in a year's
time okay talking about the same things
is it not though a serious upscale by
NATO countries or in the situation in
Ukraine where does that leave us
it's an upscale in terms of the
capability but it's not an upscale in
principle we have been providing all
kinds of military hardware to the
ukrainians really since the start of
this war and indeed before this is
different it's not it's not as if we're
saying there should be a no-fly zone and
NATO aircraft will be flying over over
Ukraine that would be
tantamount to the West actually
physically getting involved with our own
Manpower this is merely an upping of the
scale of equipment that we're giving
them and giving them an offensive
capability I don't see the issue of
principle there and as I've just been
saying I think it's the right thing to
do to give the ukrainians a chance to
win this war Because unless they win
this war this war is going to drag on
how finally how secure is Putin do you
think in his position
I think is increasingly insecure
um I think he's insecure from a variety
of threats one is the ultra nationalist
not Ultra hardliners in the Kremlin who
don't disagree with the war but disagree
with the way that he's been running it
um and then I think there are others who
actually are increasingly beginning to
realize that this whole special military
operation a war Now by Any Other Name is
doing no good for Russia's reputation no
good for Russia's economy and therefore
there are other groups that could be
putting pressure on him I've I've said
it before and I'll say it again I think
the group of Russian leaders who are
probably the most disaffected at the
present moment are the Russian military
leaders headed by karasimov if he could
find a plan and the moral courage to see
it through I could see a palace coup a
Kremlin coup being led by krasimov
because the Army is absolutely fed up
with the interference that Putin has
been exercising personally they're
desperately upset if you like by the way
that corruption in their procurement
system produced on weapons that are
manifestly inferior to Western weapons
so I think we need to watch karasimov
quite quite carefully he could be the
one for the um Julius Caesar moment to
stick in the knife and do you think that
Putin is very aware of that which is why
we've seen the latest development I'm
quite sure he's aware of it he's
probably trying to hold grazimov in
quite close but also putting the stakes
on tourism of that um if you fail well
then you're out
um so I think what's going on in the
Kremlin and of course we don't know in
detail we're only picking up scraps of
information and trying to analyze them
but I think it's a very interesting time
of what's going on in the Kremlin at the
present moment keep your friends close
and your enemies closer that's it key
okay my Lord thank you very much for
joining us thank you